okay welcome uh everyone to
the refugee and migration uh Workshop uh
I'm Stephen Wilkinson I'm the director
of the McMillan uh Center uh within
which the program is located it gives me
my uh very great pleasure today uh to
welcome my friend and colleague
Professor Nicholas
sanes uh to present on his work on
overcoming discrimination uh Professor
sanes uh uh is a leading Authority in
international relations he's written
really foundational works on uh Civil
War and uh peace and conflict and
intervening uh to preserve uh peace uh
and more recently his interests have
also moved towards looking at uh
domestic politics and overcoming
discrimination around the world and
especially in uh Europe and that's what
he's going to be speaking on uh today
and he's recently published this book
native bias overcoming discrimination
against against immigrants which uh as
we know is is timely really everywhere
in the world so we welcome also the
people who are watching uh online you
can submit questions uh in the chat and
have a chance to have Professor sanes
answer those uh in the Q&A so welcome
Professor
sanas thank you thank you very much for
this uh
invitation I was asked to uh present
this
book uh that was coauthored with uh uh
Danny Choy and uh uh Matias torner who
are post doctor fellows at my lab the
identity conflict Lab at pan and now
assistant professors at Brown and LLC
respectively and the topic of the of the
conversation uh today and of the book is
uh is on uh strategies to reduce n bias
against immigrants Muslim immigrants in
particular in Europe and the title of
the convers of the the uh presentation
as you can see is can share Norms of
good citizenship reduce native immigrant
culture uh and I will we're motivated to
stud study this
topic uh by by uh the observations that
are being made constantly uh around
Europe that natives are actually opposed
to immigration you see in your screen
here uh data from several countries in
Europe um with people responding to the
question uh uh uh that there are so many
immigrants living here that it doesn't
feel like home anymore and you see that
in Italy France and Germany for example
about half of the population agrees with
that statement in Greece where I'm from
uh 85% of the population uh in a survey
that was done I believe in 2020 uh I
would agree with the statement that the
number of immigrants is too large and
the percentage agreeing among the young
people age 17 to 34 who are usually more
liberal U more accepting uh than older
people is 70% which is huge um uh and uh
56% of the population believe that
immigrants are actually negative have a
negative impact on the economy which is
strange because there are entire sectors
of the Greek economy that just do not
operate without migrant labor like
Agriculture and tourism and construction
for example uh and
84% uh prefer all refugees who arrived
with a at the 2015 uh Refugee crisis to
leave
Greece these are pretty staggering
numbers suggesting hostility towards
immigrants and one of the objectives of
this book and of the broader project
that I'll talk to you about today is to
uncover the causes of IM bias and then
to consider potential strategies to
reduce that so there are there is a very
large literature and political science
on this topic particularly on causes of
of native bias and causes of prejudice
in general towards all kinds of minority
groups not just
immigrants um and I've organized them
here in a in a list of so the three
dominant um explanations are one that it
might be racism and just uh
xenophobia Prejudice towards any group
that is not part of the group and is
culturally or different with respect to
any kind of a SP characteristics there
is some evidence of this uh both with
respect to to uh immigrant groups but
also other minority groups a second very
popular uh explanation is that economic
competition between native uh Natives
and immigrants is what explains
hostility towards immigrants you know
this is very popular explanation in the
United States um and also in Europe but
interestingly there is very little
evidence to support this you know from
cross country studies uh so the least
likely explanation is that one uh as far
as the literature is concerned at the
moment and then the third and the most
likely explanation for what causes bias
against immigrants is that cultural
differences between the native
population and the Immigrant groups uh
create the perception of threat um and
that is what motivates natives to to
react against immigration because they
perceive immigrants as potentially
changing the national identity right so
they see uh the
symbols um of cultural difference of
immigrants in this picture here it's the
hijab that these women are wearing as a
symbol of of of change that is unwelcome
in in uh in Native Society so
uh the theory um
um the theory that we develop in the
book is is grounded in Social
psychological theories of Intergroup
conflict that are not specific to Native
immigrant relations but we extend those
uh to some extent and we apply insights
from these literatures and and what I
have here in bold is the statement that
conflict over waves of life is at the
heart of opposition to multiculturalism
in Europe that's that's uh I think the
theoretical perspective that has
received the most support in uh survey
based and experimental research in uh in
political science in Europe and and the
reason is that natives have priors and
stereotypes about the extent to which
immigrants live by different rules and
different norms and also the extent to
which these Norms are just different
from from from their own and that
generates social distance between
Natives and inds right so uh the larger
that social distance the larger the bias
and that's an Insight that comes out of
the the literature and Social
Psychology that I mentioned earlier and
Native bias the book that I'm presenting
today tests the power of shared norms
and ideas to reduce expressions of
native immigrant hostility by reducing
the perception of social distance
separating these groups so and in an
ongoing the book is out already so I'll
present the empirical results from the
book but I'll also at the end discuss
some extensions that I have ongoing
currently right so I mentioned that the
theory uh the theoretical foundation of
the book uh lies in social psychology
literature that goes back decades in
particular social identity Theory and
which uh has taught us that any kind of
ascriptive or other group based
difference can generate bias even if
those differences are not felt deeply
and they don't have bag so we can create
artificial groups in the lab and assign
people to these groups and that will
generate hostility and competition
between between the two groups um and a
lot of that literature has then gone on
to try to figure out ways to reduce bias
and reduce conflict between groups um
and um Expressions versions of of those
arguments have found their way in
political science and and there are some
arguments out there about ways to reduce
um conflict between Natives and
immigrants that cons that require
immigrants to assimilate completely to
Native Society by shedding the markers
of their difference right so
assimilating by adapting names that are
not visibly foreign for example or
changing the religion so these forms of
cive uh
assimilation
um are just opposed to the types of
strategies that we're considering in
this book which are far less coercive
and which consist of uh converging on a
set of norms of good citizenship that uh
if applied if used and implemented in
everyday settings both by uh Natives and
immigrants can generate the perception
that everyone is part of a common in
group a citizen in group and by doing so
that should reduce the import of
ascriptive markers and cultural
differences
uh that can persist right so in other
ways in other words if immigrants behave
in ways that that natives perceived as
not threatening Vis A norms and values
that they that they share then they
should no longer care about any visible
markers of difference racial ethnic
religious or other markers that
immigrants might have and therefore
there should be less pressure for
immigrants to to assimilate by sheding
those markers that's idea here and by
the way you can jump in with questions
um anytime you like in the
presentation so uh the data from for uh
this book comes from experiments that we
run in
Germany uh between 2018 and uh 2019 and
for the field experiments and expanded
later with some survey experiments in
2020 and 2021 we chose Germany because
it was one of two countries that were
most affected by the refugee crisis of
2015 the other one being Greece and
Germany received more than one and a
half million applications for Asylum
after the
Syrian refugee crisis and over uh a long
period even prior to 2015 there was
growing opposition to
multiculturalism um but it it's not the
most uh uh anti-immigrant nation in
Europe Italy and Hungary probably hold
that uh this distinction right now at
least Germany is about in the middle
like if you look at indices of
opposition to multiculturalism in Europe
Germany is uh is roughly in the middle
right so it's a it's a large country
that's important and has a very large
population of of migrants going back
Generations since the postwar period
when they had the worker program
um and so it has had a lot of experience
with with uh with foreign uh popul
ations and it was hit really hard in
this recent um crisis therefore it's a
good it's a good case study and what we
did uh to to generate data for this
project is that we created what we call
Micro environments of social
interactions designed to observe the
degree of assistance that is offered to
strangers in everyday interactions right
so we focus on everyday settings in
which people interact with each other um
because we we feel that this gives us a
glimpse um into the types of of uh of
information that people receive about
others uh information about the extent
to which uh one is accepted or or or
excluded in society right so uh the idea
is that um if You observe a stranger
offering you help in in one instance and
this happens many many times times over
time that will generate your percept
that will shape your perceptions of the
degree to which uh you're accepted as an
equal uh uh in that Society so these
everyday settings that we analyze in
this in this
um uh
project are interactions in train
stations actually platforms when people
wait the train to go to work or travel
Germany has many large cities with many
large stations and there are stations
with like 20 30 21 or 24 platforms so uh
and and people just gather there and
there's a constant stream of of new
people uh who sit for a while and then
leave and and that gives us access to a
lot of bystanders whose Behavior we can
observe in real time in a real setting
um after exposing them to an experiment
uh an intervention that they do not know
there there is is already official and
is set up by us so in I'm going to
present two experiments of this sort
here plus a bunch of survey experiments
that we did to uh tease apart specific
mechanisms that can explain the results
from the fuel experiments the first one
consists of a stage
violation of the norm against literary
which Germans care a lot about in
actually another reason why Germany is a
good case for this analysis is because
they care a lot about rules right so
rule following is a norm in its own
right no matter what kind of so if you
ride the bike at night in Germany
without a light people scream at you
everywhere if you cross the street uh
people yell at you from both sides of
the street if you have a child while you
scream across the street they're going
to scream even more you know so uh it's
a good it's a good U it's a good test
case and at the end of the talk I'm
going to compare it a little bit to
Greece which is precisely the opposite
uh people in general don't follow Norms
they only care if you follow norms and
no one is going to intervene to make
sure that you follow the norm um so we
have a multicountry study that we we're
developing
now uh with Len Kulu who is a post
associated with my lab he an economist
based in Greece and Chris Kowski was an
assistant professor at uh Kings college
that um that makes CrossCountry
comparisons of the sort that that I'm
going to talk to you about today but
today I will only focus on German so I'm
going to present the setup of the of the
experiment really briefly I'll show you
some footage and I'll show you the
results and then I'll move on to the
next one so in this experiment we care
about these guys experimental subjects
which are basically ordinary Germans
waiting in train station to get on a
train basically they can be standing
they can be
sitting uh and a member of our team
always male will come in and buy at the
norm against littering by dropping cup
paper cup with coffee doesn't have
coffee in it but he just finished it
we'll drop it on the on the platform and
then another member of the team always a
woman will in some cases intervene to
tell this guy to pick up his trash
basically
um and uh and please place the the paper
in a in a trash can uh
thereby signaling to those people here
that she cares about Norms about
cleanliness and about the country
basically right uh then this team member
will take a call okay someone will call
her and she will have a
conversation um that is loud enough for
these people here to to hear uh and in
The Next Step she will drop a bunch of
possessions that she's cradling in a
paper bag uh the possessions are
groceries oranges actually the back is
torn at the bottom and uh she she's
instructed to make a sudden move Dr her
bag which will force her to move her arm
and then the oranges will fall on the
floor they will disperse on the ground
and we observe whether these guys help
her pick them up that's the setup right
uh I'm going to show I'm going to go
back into the details and I'll tell you
which are the experimental Dimensions
that we manipulate in a little bit but
first I'll show you
uh a a video of this interaction if I
can figure out how to start it there we
go this is Danilo H science student Dro
this cup and that's NL is
Turkish you see these women here already
talking
about this woman here is working with us
and she's going to record the reactions
and this one also they have two coders
working the
T thr him off
the three women are talking about him
this guy doesn't
care now she's taking her
call I she's talking to a friend about
coming to see
her now she's instructed not to pick up
these oranges for five seconds so that
after she so that we can give these
people a chance to pick them up so this
woman here and the other one who you saw
was standing on that side have recorded
uh some information first of all there
recorded um the number of bystanders who
were sitting whether they were sitting
or not the gender of the bystanders uh a
subjective estimate of their age are
they old or young basically can they get
up and out or not basically and some
other things like is anybody on a
wheelchair cane all that and most
importantly did anybody help right so
our main outcome in the study is did
anyone helped this woman pick up her
oranges and also how many people helped
is a second area outcome
right uh so that's the that's the
Intervention basically right and the key
here is that these people didn't know
that they were part of an
experiment
um and uh we believe that by by
generating the situations and collecting
data this way we get a more organic and
and true estimate of uh the willingness
to help than it would be the case if we
just ask them in a survey would you help
somebody in need in fact we've done this
and there's a massive difference between
the stated willingness to help people
and the actual uh help that they provide
now what's the experiment manipulating
right so the first there are three
dimensions the identity of the
Confederate the language of the phone
call and Norm enforcement so in the
first uh treatment Dimension we
manipulate the ascriptive
characteristics of the female
Confederate who does the nor enforcement
here you see Stephanie who's German uh
and is our native control in this study
and EML who is Kurdish uh and she she
was actually a a refugee uh uh in um
turkey and became a student now here
you'll see that EML is uh wearing a a
hijab in one condition no hijab she's
basically dressed the same way that
Stephanie is dressed the way most women
of her age are dressed in Germany
students and then here she's wearing a
big cross you know like George
Michael uh level cross you know that's
very visible from uh uh far away to
signal that she's Christian right so the
idea here is that social distance
between EML and Stephanie increases as
you go this direction right right to
left and our hypothesis drawing from
social identity Theory which says that
there is in group bias whenever you
highlight um group differences between
between two groups is that ml is going
to get much less help in this condition
here compared to the other two
conditions where she's visibly less
distant from the Native control but she
will in all cases we expect her to
receive less help than
stepan the second dimension that we
manipulate is Norm enforce right so I
won't go through this whole whole thing
again we're focus on just on these two
things so as I mentioned um our female
Punisher will sometimes enforce the norm
tell the guy to pick up his trash other
times she won't do anything she won't
care basically she will just sit there
and look at the trash and then mind her
own business there's always enforcement
in uh in these experiments right so
there is a another team member uh who is
also a woman who comes in and tells so
somebody always tells this guy to pick
up his trash and we did that for two
reasons first in Germany somebody's
going to tell this guy to pick up his
trash anyway so we wanted to do it first
before the there's
intervention by the by and second there
is a literature in Psychology I'm not
sure how how robust the findings are
that there are
these spel over Effects by observing uh
positive behavior for example um so if
You observe something for social
somebody doing something nice then you
might also respond in a nice way on an
entirely different matter you know uh so
we wanted to keep Pro social the the
observation of pro social behavior
constant throughout these experiments
because what we really care about was
whether differences in the identity of
the person making the the experiment um
uh making
the nor enforcement really drivve the
results so we always had someone
enforcing the norm right yes um maybe
I'm anticipating um a little bit but
would you run the experiment also with
different gender for the Violator and
The
Punisher uh yes so that's a question
that we we get a lot and it would be NE
to do that we didn't do that because
there were 14 conditions in this
experiment so then it would have gotten
just you want to just blown up uh
logistically and that's actually the
reason why in these extensions that I'm
going to talk about at the end we use uh
calibrated adaptations of these
interventions in a survey based setting
that is much more cost effective and
allows us to to to check these
variations uh we chose women here
because we thought that it was less
likely that there's going to be trouble
basically uh like if you had a woman
littering and a Muslim immigrant man
telling her off that could have been a
dangerous situation in some of the towns
that we went to for example but nobody
is gonna you know be violent against the
woman who's actually behaving in aocial
way and forcing the nor it would be
pretty crazy actually and it never
happened
um so that was the reason why why we did
this but obviously and I think also
helping Behavior tends to be higher uh
higher Baseline for women than it would
be for for men some guy drug sheets or
just like pick them up so these were the
reasons why we now the the third
dimension which I won't talk much about
in this uh in this presentation as part
of the ex of the of the of the
experiment nonetheless is the language
of the phone call so the the woman um
who was holding the the the oranges and
either made the intervention to enforce
the norm or not always took a call
actually the guy who was leaving was the
one calling her and uh he she spoke to
him in uh either in German or in Arabic
or Turkish okay I always had the same
same uh script that we gave her
basically which was about oh I'm excited
to come see you it was something
irrelevant basically and the whole idea
it was was to make the call sound like
she's talking to a friend and therefore
if she's talking to a friend in German
that means that she has German friends
and therefore she's assimilated uh to
some extent and her network includes
Germans right uh which you would expect
if the native if it's a native but you
might not expect if she's a hijab
wearing uh Middle Eastern woman right
and that could also influence
behavior so that's the experiment now
where did we do this we did this in
train stations in 31 cities and towns
across three states in former East
Germany and in West Germany here right
uh so there were H 34 Confederates
across seven teams in and these blue
dots here are the different cities um
and we were fortunate that Germany has
uh so many cities with train stations
that we can do this uh I have Pilots
going on now in Greece where I'm trying
to do something like this and it's like
impossible basically and uh so we're
doing it like bus stations and Metro
stations every public space you can
imagine you know it's and it's crazy
complicated logistically right so uh we
ran the intervention
1,614 times and alog together that
involves a little more than 7,000 by
standards and we have 14 treatment and
control conditions when you combine the
manipulations for the three Dimensions
which is why we didn't have
male uh enforces for example or consider
other interesting potentially
interesting variations of this
um so the main outcome as I mentioned
was did any bystander offer assistance
and and there are logistical details of
this skit basically which I won't get
into but but uh you know you can't drop
the orange here and expect somebody from
way down there to run and get it
although that happened once uh this
little girl sprinted across you know
like 20 M to try to help you know uh but
it had to be within three meters
basically right more or less and the
oranges had to be on the ground for a
few seconds not so long that it becomes
weird that you haven't bent down to pick
them up yourself uh but long enough to
give people a chance
to uh pick them up plus other there's
another there was like a long protocol
about you know what counts as help what
doesn't um
the results I'm going to show you here
uh refer to whether this binary
indicator whether any bystander uh
helped or not and in this experiment we
only did it in settings where there were
multiple bystandard right never just
oneon-one the next experiment that I'm
going to show you we also did one-on-one
uh interactions and that kind of matters
actually uh so the hypothesis as I
mentioned is that that just flows
straight out of social psychological the
theories of social identity is that um
uh people will receive less assistance
uh from bystanders if they're different
and the more different they are there
was the less assistance They will
receive these are the first two and that
signaling cultural integration by Valu
by enforcing valued Civic Norms will
offset the bias that we anticipate
finding um against Muslim immigrant
enforcement uh Muslim immigrants these
are main hypotheses so I won't give give
you I won't talk about any technical
details in in this uh presentation I'll
just show some bar graphs basically but
we can discuss details if you want uh
the the main one of the main results is
that there is biased against um
immigrants on the basis of religion in
Germany the blue uh column here shows
you that providing help is fairly common
right 78% of the cases there was some
help given to the to the
Confederate when the ger when the when
the Confederate was a German native
woman uh and it wasn't much different
when it was an immigrant woman wearing a
cross or an immigrant woman in the
control condition dressed in modern
clothes looking secular basically right
so these first three columns here
suggest that phenotypical differences
just looking like you're not really
German basically whatever that means
whatever people think of germanness
doesn't really matter very much in
Germany nor does the language actually
matter which is very interesting because
in other countries in particular in the
United States other experiments have
shown that they matter a lot right so
there's an interesting experiment done
by Ryan Enos at Harvard in Boston where
he shows that even just planting some uh
Confederates who who are Latinos and
they look visibly Latino in subway
stations generates more uh generates
more hostile attitudes towards
affirmative action among the commuters
for example so even seeing someone who's
different racially and listening to
Spanish can generate hostile responses
in the United States not in Germany
which suggests that they're actually
much
more okay with cultural differences and
nothing difference which is what you
would expect when you have such a large
uh foreign worker population of course
we would expect the same thing in the
United States but it's not not true now
um this is interesting here if you
compare columns three and four you see
the
penalty uh that women incur out of just
showing that they believe different
things than the than the average German
believes by wearing the hijab so on
average women immigrant women wearing
hijab get help 66% of the time which is
pretty good you know more than half the
time but much less significantly less uh
than immigrant the same woman not
wearing a hug job
right who gets helped 76% of the time
there's a 10% difference and that's the
amount of the penalty basically that you
get from for being different uh in this
everyday interaction you might say well
10% is that a lot I don't know if it's a
lot but it is what we picked up and it's
also a fairly Costless way
of of uh helping someone right like it
it's for someone who is like not have a
bad back or something it's nothing to
bend down and and pick up an orange
especially if the orange hits your leg
or it's closer to you than somebody else
so to withhold that assistance
systematically um towards someone on the
basis of what they look like what you
think they believe is a significant um
uh expression of hostility we think
that's how we interpret this now does
Norm
enforcement change these results in some
way right so we find that actually bias
is partially offset by uh by shared
Norms but it's not completely eliminated
right so we here starting again by
German enforcer we see that they get
helped about 84% of the time
significantly more than the previous uh
data that I showed you uh and there is a
statistically significant difference in
the amount of Health that the German
native gets when she enforces a norm
versus not right so she gets more help
when she enforces the norm um when the
Immigrant wearing a hijab enforces the
norm she also gets much more help uh
than when she does not uh there is now a
12 and a half% difference right so so
the hijab penalty increases uh when um
when um
um uh there is
uh uh also enforcement versus non
enforcement but the an interesting
finding is that uh the amount of help
that the Immigrant woman wearing a hijab
gets when she
enforces the the norb is basically the
same as the amount of help that the
German woman gets when she does not
enforce the so this is an example
of what you hear frequently being said
uh in the United States in other
countries which is that minorities and
immigrants have to work twice as hard to
get basically the same kind of treatment
that natives get right so like uh these
women get helped the same way but this
Middle Eastern woman here um wearing
hijab has gone out of her way way to
confront this big German dude you know
for being rude uh whereas this woman is
just
white and they get help the same so uh
while while we see this increase right
from from uh 60% to 73% and is
statistically significant and therefore
we know that uh pro-social Behavior by
immigrants is
recognized uh there's still a difference
in difference basically and and
immigrant women I'm sorry native women
still get helped more right uh this is
not trivial though right because it
could have been the case that noral
enforcement was completely
discounted uh when when
um when done by by an immigrant right so
and we didn't find that so it could have
been the case that that these columns
were equal right so maybe people didn't
and he and the fact that they're not
suggest that Germans actually value Norm
enforcement and and rules more than the
antipathy that many of them feel towards
other people or uh it suggests that um
the reason that they have this antipathy
might be that they make assumptions
about the things that immigrants
actually believe right so when you
resolve that uncertainty and you show
them that they actually share the same
ideas to some extent um that the
negative or immigrants is reduced so
that's the main result can I ask you
something yes now the third person when
she tells the guy to pick up his trash I
assume she has to speak German in German
with a slight acction okay slight accent
yes
um
so um now you might wonder why why are
um so what drives this what is the
mechanism Bally why do people uh what do
people think about when they see an
immigrant woman either reacting Pro
socially by telling the guy to pick up
his trash or not caring basically when
they she stands right next to somebody
who who who l so we to figure that out
uh because we didn't have data on this
from from our field experiment we ran a
a survey
experiment um in um maybe few months
later I believe 2020
where we showed videos from these um
from these
um uh inter interventions and pictures
of litter streets and collected data on
basically beliefs about littering uh
about why Germans litter why immigrants
litter who litters more and so on and we
found out that the majority of Germans
think that immigrants litter more than
Germans um and when you ask them why in
an open-ended respon response and you do
a little work cloud of their responses
you see that this word homeland and
respect and habit are are is what comes
up more frequently in spontaneous
responses about you know why the
immigrants litter they litter because
they're not from here this is in their
Homeland they don't really care they
don't have the Habit not to litter right
which suggest that it's all about
respect and showing respect uh and and
affinity for the new country right so
when and that is what registers when
they observe an immigrant woman uh
enforcing the norm that she actually
does care and she respects uh the
country that she lives in now and and
therefore she can be considered part of
the citizen in group but on the basis of
this experiment that is not enough to
eliminate all bias right because there's
still a difference in difference in the
results I showed
you so uh we so far we've learned that
Germans discriminate against Muslims in
everyday interactions to some extent
that ethnol linguistic differences and
phenotypical differences don't really
matter uh and therefore this these these
these this discrimination might must be
driven by what people read into these
ascriptive differences right what do
they think the hijab means for example
uh and that these perceptions of
normative differences uh with immigrants
that underly uh that bias uh
can be manipulated and when you change
them that can reduce the bias but not
eliminate so what are the mechanisms
underlying this again right so social
psychological theory in particular
commoning group identity model uh which
um uh was developed by Gardner and doido
who is here Gale um suggest some
possible explanations and mechanisms to
mechanism that they have suggested is
recategorization and decategorization
right so the idea is that you can reduce
Prejudice to someone else if you can
redefine that person as a member of a
common in group right rather than a
member of a hostile app Group what can
this common in group be uh when we're
dealing with Natives and immigrants it
can't be a national in group but it
could be a citizen in group right so the
idea that we had here is that if
everyone behaves the same way and they
show that they share the same ideas
about standards of appropriate Civic
Behavior they can be part of a of a
shared uh citizen in group and and that
is the way that they can be
recategorized as an ingroup member from
an out group member or an a different
mechanism is that they can be
decategorization
Grand woman with a hijab who's enforcing
the norm and think of her as a citizen a
good citizen not as a Muslim or you can
look at her and say yeah yeah she's a
Muslim but she's a good Muslim not a bad
Muslim like the others basically right
so the first would be recategorization
the second would be decategorization
mechanism so and and a third and we
wanted to test these mechanisms and a
third thing that we wanted to test is
whether the benefit of pro social
behavior that is generated by
observing uh normal enforcement by one
person generalizes to the group or is it
restricted to the person itself right so
so so to do that we ran another survey
experiment which consisted of uh showing
people videos right now this video
here
um was filmed by us and it was as if
randomly captured on the on the phone
right so Matias was sitting here on a in
a a bench and he was taking a video with
his phone of the surroundings in the
back right he was saying oh look they
finished the construction in the station
you know how the way people do all the
time and then they post the stuff on
YouTube or Tik Tok right and then as he
was doing that these people walk into
the frame right and and then we replic
replicate repeated this intervention not
the norm enforcement just the littering
I'm sorry uh not the the orang
part just a norm violation and the
enforcement right so this guy who's
pretty huge actually and you wouldn't
want to tell him off you
know about police around you or
something uh drops his cup and then this
woman who's pretty small uh actually
tells him to pick up his trash uh or not
you know so in one iteration she just
sits there and they're actually her
friends are sitting just off that frame
there were there were some versions in
which there were a group of of four and
other versions in which she was
alone uh so we have an experiment again
in which Norm violation is
either uh sanctioned or not sanctioned
by a woman who who is either a Muslim
woman wearing hijab or a German woman
right so we have videos of all of these
different uh conditions and we upload
the them on YouTube in an account and a
channel that we we uh
created um we let them sit there for a
while and then we we use the link in a
survey instrument saying look um we want
to know what you think about these
situations which we found online
including this video that we happen to
find online so it's as if it's a real
intervention that we captured uh in the
field and we we implemented in we
implement the survey uh in a sample of 2
and a half th000 uh German adults in
November
2020 and we are interested in measuring
responses using this item basically so
after they view the video um they're
asked to consider whether the person in
the video uh is similar and how similar
that person is to an upstanding German
citizen right are they 0% similar 20%
similar 40% and so on until identical
basically this is a common way of
measuring uh perceive similarity in
American volage literature and in
economics um and we call this the rec
the so recategorization it because the
idea is that if the person in question
is a is an immigrant wearing a hijab and
you think that she is 100% similar to a
good upstanding citizen then you're
thinking about her as as a citizen
rather than as a as a The Foreigner
right uh because an upstanding German
citizen would have done exactly what uh
a person did in the iterations where
they enforced the norm right so I won't
show you all the analysis I'll just give
you a snapshot of the results and the
results are that Norman forces are seen
as more similar to good Germans series
regardless of whether they were hijab or
no hijab the hijab no longer mats
basically right so we have a a very
large shift
um from zero to 100 although it's not
100 again uh and Norm en forcers so we
have evidence of the recategorization
mechanism and Norm en forcers are seen
as not typical members of the group
right when the normal forcer is an
immigrant right so uh a Muslim woman
enforcing the norm uh is seen as more
similar to a good German citizen and
because she's not a typical Muslim right
so that's the these are these are the
main results here and the
benefit uh of Norm enforcement seeing
this Norm enforcement in in the video
doesn't change your views of Muslims as
a group in general right so yes you
recognize that this one person did
something good yes is closer to a good
German citizen but mods as a whole are
still as bad or as good as you thought
about previously
right so there is evidence of both
recategorization and decategorization
and this one shot
intervention uh that we did in the in
the video doesn't really change
perceptions of the group in general that
might also be true is probably true in
the field as well so seeing somebody
doing something something good in the
field who's from a different out group
is probably not going to change your
world view about everybody else uh but
our hypothesis is that if you were to
see examples of such Pro social behavior
over and over again by many different
people everywhere that should over time
change your your views right that's
still
untested
so now you might ask
well what about other Norms okay so we
talked about
littering um but littering is kind of a
generic not littering is a generic Civic
Norm
everybody kind of
feels uh the same way about it it's hard
to find someone who's going to tell you
in a survey yes I'd like to litter you
know but maybe we'll have maybe the
reason that we find that the diffing
diff still still there is because
uh enforcing a non literary Norm has
shallow effects right you'll give
somebody the
benefit um uh of saying that you feel a
little closer to that person because
they enforce the norm but it's not going
to change the way you feel about that
person massively what about if we focus
on group specific
norms and by that we remain Civic Norms
that affect your subgroup of the
population more right to do this
generate strong effects and here we
focus on gender equity and and Norms
about uh gender roles in particular and
we expect
that
um we hypothesize that the reason that
women wearing a hijab in Germany get
penalized and discriminated against in
these public settings is because people
make assumptions about their beliefs
regarding gender equality she hijab they
assume that the woman is is regressive
Vis A
uh gender equality norms and they punish
her for that by not helping her once she
needs help what if we actually were able
to communicate the woman's beliefs about
gender roles uh in the same way that we
did in the previous experiment would
that change things in the field so we
designed and another experiment that
tested exactly that right so our
hypothesis is that discrimination
against
Muslims is likely driven by beliefs that
they have regressive ideas about gender
that is a big topic actually in
Immigration studies of immigration in
Europe gender and and the role of women
in society uh in Muslim societies versus
Christian societies is a point of
conflict uh and
debate uh uh so we confirm actually that
this assumption is widely shared in
Germany in a standard survey so we we
tell them what do you think about hijab
for example and repression is what comes
immediately as the the most commonly
mentioned word um in the survey so we
said well what if Muslim women signal
that they actually have Progressive
ideas about German does that reduce
discrimination and does that make the
hijab just an irrelevant cultural uh
symbol that they were for other reasons
right uh rather than to Signal political
uh ideology that is contrary to the
dominant view in Germany and we did that
with another field experiment the
following summer summer of 2019 which
had the same idea but we dropped lemons
this time so rather than orang right so
uh here is nesla she's the same woman
that you saw before she loved being part
of this whole thing so she Rea this the
second she lived in Cologne and she was
a political science student she's
Turkish so she approaches a group of
people who could be standing or talking
or sitting and she takes a call right
and in the call she will reveal her
beliefs about gender equality and I'll
tell you how so um we manipulate two
Dimensions here the first is the
identity of the Confederate just like in
the previous one she can be a German
native this is Charlotte uh she she was
in one of the East German uh teams and
this is ranim who's a Syrian refugee uh
and and here is ranim in the control
condition wearing no hijab and here is
ranim wearing hijab basically right so
we have three conditions immigrant hijab
immigrant no hijab and
Native and these women dressed uh uh
depending on the way that the condition
they were assigned to uh suggest they
should be dressed would approach this
group and have a conversation in which
they
um reveal their views on gender by
saying one of these three things so in
one condition she will she will uh speak
she's always speaking to a friend of
hers and she's uh expressing her uh uh
emotional state about a decision that
her sister took to either take a job H
or not right so in the regressive
condition message she says hi thanks for
calling back I'm really mad my sister is
a terrible mother uh there's a word for
that in German that people really pay
attention to they listen to it like
Raven Raven mother although I don't know
if Ravens are mothers or not uh she
prefers to work instead of looking after
her children and her husband at home and
then there's a pause and then she says I
think that as a woman she should stay at
home and look after her family I've
never been so mad since we moved to
Germany we added this sentence to make
clear that these people were actually
immigrants or recent immigrants because
that wasn't actually clear in the first
experiment uh and then in the
Progressive message it's the same
setting the sister takes a job or not
but she's happy about that right so a
woman I'm really happy very proud of my
sister uh she decided to go to work she
shouldn't just stay at home to look
after children and husband and the
control condition she basically has a
similarly similar length conversation
with a friend about some irrelevant
subject oh I'm coming to see you I'm
excited uh blah blah blah right so and
what does the control person say then
regarding
Germany
uh she says uh I'm
happy I'm happy to come to see you and
then something happened in her life I
can't remember what we said now and then
uh it ends with basically the same thing
I'm I'm I'm I'm happy uh so she's happy
in the control happy in the Progressive
and mad in the regressive
um now the data collection here uh
lasted five weeks 25 cities in uh in 26
train stations in in NRV Saxon in lower
Saxony and here we repeated this
iteration 1,830 times and we had almost
4,000 bystanders right again within 3
meters in a pilot the spring before uh
Matias and I did went to frankurt and we
ran this like about 250 times and we
then had a team of people come and
interview everybody who was around so we
established that in like 98% of the
times they noticed the Confederate 96%
of the time they noticed the call and
86% of the times they could tell you
exactly what she said even when they
were wearing headphones which is pretty
weird I think but that's it is what it
is you know so very nosy
people uh who want to know what's going
on around them which works for this
experiment quite well so here we collect
data on how many bystanders there were
and we collect in this instance we were
better at it so we had individual level
data did we we had up to seven
bystanders and then for each
bystander uh was was he what's the
gender of that person were they wearing
headphones what is the subjective
estimate of the age bracket are they
potentially of immigrant background
that's all subjective obviously uh and
did this by Stander offer assistance and
that allows us to analyze the data both
by iteration did anybody help in that
iteration or not but also to say
something about women help more or not
and that was
useful because after the intervention we
had a survey another team came in uh a
few minutes later and said oh we're from
this University in this town we're
running the survey during the study can
we do a survey uh about social issues in
Germany
it was extremely hard to get people to
say yes to that unfortunately and we
didn't really get great data we tried
everything tried giving away
$2,000 uh we tried this weird system
where we gave them these cards and we
could track them so they can actually
take the survey later when they wanted
to and they never work well basically
but we have some data that we can
actually match with the individual level
data and that present that that gives us
some interesting find
actually so the first result is that uh
we replicate the finding from the
previous summer which is that there is
bias on the basis of religion right we
have the average level of help is about
the same 76% it was 78% in
2018 uh for the native and it's
basically the same for the Immigrant
control no discrimination there but it's
67 and a half% for the Immigrant with
the hijab and that difference is
statistically significant exactly the
same as before um and here is the
interesting stuff here so lots of
Dimensions here to
consider the First Dimension is just
compare the bluish columns with the
reddish columns and we see that the
bluish columns which are all about
natives the different conditions
Progressive neutral or regressive in the
natives are all about the same whereas
uh the are differences in immigrants so
basically uh what these native women say
doesn't really influence whether they
get help or not so uh whereas for
immigrants it matters quite a bit
whether they appear to be Progressive or
regressive right and the progressive
woman wearing a hijab gets helped uh
just as much there's no statistically
significant difference as the German
woman in any any condition right so
there's no longer any bias uh towards
Muslim women when they appear to be
regressive in that result is driven by
women German women German women no
longer discriminate against Muslim women
when the Muslim woman appears to be
Progressive there is H significant
penalty to wearing a hijab when it is
associated confirming the priors that
this woman is
regressing uh but there is no analogous
penalty to being regressive if you're
German right so that in and of itself
can be interpreted as a subtle sign of
bias right so basically uh white German
women are allowed to have whatever views
they have and you'll still help them but
the Muslim women that's not the case
basically right so you help them only if
they show you that they believe the same
thing that you believe now
men are not affected At All by this
intervention right uh it doesn't change
their reaction in fact they discriminate
a little more against women in any of in
the Progressive uh uh condition and the
regressive condition relative to the to
the control like whenever they talk
basically it upsets them a little bit
and they and and they they they help
them a little less but it's only a very
very small uh annoyance
penalty so but they don't care basically
if the Muslim women are regressive so
there's something else that's driving
male uh discrimination against Muslim
women uh and the third uh finding which
comes from the individual level data is
that this entire set of results comes
from
secular there's a 50 percentage points
difference in the help rate among among
women who declare to be religious and
women who declare to be atheist and the
atheist uh the secular women in Germany
are the ones who
appreciate uh the progressive message
Christian women do not in fact uh
sometimes punish the the German women
for for that position right just as in
the previous example we follow up uh
with a survey experiment to figure out
exactly why do people um
uh uh discriminate against the hijab
wearing women and we ran a survey
showing them a video of one of our
Confederates when she wears a hijab who
drops her oranges in front of these
German people and nobody helps her and
we asked them why do you think she
doesn't get any help and the most common
explanation like at 65% of the people
give you immediately is that it's
because they think that
she uh does not not think that women are
equal and they think women should be
subordinate right so the whole idea here
is that um when when people look at the
hijab as a symbol of Islam they assume
that it's a symbol of political Islam
and that it means that that um it
represents a set of politically
regressive beliefs which can if you
allow a lot of Muslims to come in and
live in Germany uh shape the politics of
the country and cusing backtracking on
advances in women's rights that have
occurred time right so that's what as
Foundation that we believe drives the
results that we find and men are not
responsive to this because they don't
really care that much about the progress
that is made in women's RS because they
don't really benefit from this just just
to to close basically because I told you
I'll tell you where this is
going
so uh we're interested in these
questions you know does race play a role
what if the
what if the enforcer is male uh what if
we're talking about other Norms you know
not just littering and gender Equity
it's extremely complicated to do this in
the field these experiments are
massively complicated logistically so we
were in the field from like 7 in the
morning until 78 at night every day uh
for five six weeks at a time and we had
55 people working across the country
basically uh for uh for
um so it's not possible to look at these
uh in a field experiment setting so what
we're doing now is we're creating
calibrated versions of these
interventions in survey
experiments um and I can tell you a
little more about how that is done and
the idea is to to run survey experiments
in all European Union countries with
very large samples about 4,000 people
the country but we measure uh first try
to find out what Norms do you these
European citizens care about among a
larger set of norms that Define good
citizenship rank order these Norms uh
and create Norm Hier hierarchies for
every country and then see whether
people apply these hierarchies
consistently to evaluate Natives and
immigrants in every country um and that
involves basically a two states process
where we it beliefs about the Norms that
matter and perceptions about what other
people in these countries think uh is
the right way of Behaving right and that
will tell us whether there's an implicit
consensus in the European
Union uh perhaps as a result of being
part of the Union about what it means to
be a good citizen and whether those
Norms of good citizenship are applied to
judge Natives and immigrants uh
equally so
uh just to to wrap up uh we we learned
in this book that there are cultural
differences cause bias that corve
assimilation uh you know changing your
name or dropping the hijab might not be
necessary if you can
disconnect uh what these symbols
actually mean politically from from uh
the religious or other cultural uh
significance but we also learned that uh
Norm enforcement and adhering to value
Norms might actually not be enough to to
eliminate all bias
um uh and that
multiculturalism uh has has some limits
so uh you can overcome ascriptive
differences but natives will resist uh
abandoning norms and ideas that Define
their identities that they've developed
over time and they've been socialized in
for the benefit of accommodating
newcomers and the values that they
represent so there are some policy
implications s of This research as well
that we're trying to uncover uh uh now
in the work that is ongoing and one one
result is that there is no easy way of
creating like some public information
campaign that will work for everybody
and reduce bias you know so and that's
unfortunate but the the
multi-dimensionality of social
identities basically and the complicated
way in which the different identities
intersect make it impossible for us to
have a single message that will work
well for everyone and we saw that in the
gender experiment where the the message
that these women are actually
Progressive works very well on women
some women secular women but not at all
among Christian women and men are
indifferent basically right so imagine
if you had a public information campaign
basically that highlighted some feature
of an immigrant population it could work
for a subset of the population but not
for the entire population so it's very
hard to find a scalable public
information campaign that can just
eliminate prejudices and misperceptions
just like that and as a first step for
policy design that actually address
these these issues we think that uh we
need to collect more information about
first what are the priors that people
have about different immigrant groups
how do they expect them to violate to
behave which Norms do they think they
will violate and which they will adhere
to and then how much do people care
about the specific Norms uh that that
immigrants are likely to violate um and
once we have that information we can
then create citizenship classes that can
inform not just immigrants but also
natives uh about about this they can
share the information with both native
populations and immigrant populations uh
leading to uh fewer misperceptions about
the degree to which immigrants are not
Norm violators and and pushing both
groups towards a
convergence um in their public
behaviors um in adherence to a set of
norms of good citizenship that could
allow uh this recategorization mechanism
that we describe to take hold basically
so I'll stop
here question online you sure if you
join me uh thanking Professor Sani
for